so even Miller is a former senior
advisor to Donald Trump he's founder of
America First legal he joins us tonight
to assess Stephen Miller I'm just
wondering what you think of that
sort of came to that after watching this
Trump Saga for the last seven years that
seems to be the third rail really is the
foreign policy questions
yes and I lived through it Tucker I
lived through it by this man's side for
those seven years the moment that he got
the nomination we watched as the hidden
power centers in this country came out
from underneath their rocks and began to
pull the strings that they control they
began to leak information designed to
sabotage him at every turn they begin to
use every organ of control they have in
the intelligence Community the National
Security Community the law enforcement
Community to try to control him and to
control his presidency Russia is the
essential example of this they tried
desperately to keep him from pursuing to
taunt with Russia they tried desperately
to keep him from holding that Summit
with Vladimir Putin to try to have a
relationship between our two countries
now look what has happened now that he
is out of office we are on the brink of
a World War Tucker as soon as they
pushed him out of office look what
happened we are now almost in a nuclear
conflict over the borders of Ukraine so
you ask me what is Donald Trump's crime
we know it's not a financial crime we
know it's not a campaign Finance crime
his crime is refusing to bow or bend to
the corrupt and rotten foreign policy
establishment that is used to always
always get in their way in this country
and and that has much greater control
over our system and I think any of us
appreciate I mean you look at John
cornyn the Republican senator from Texas
who I think most people I'll speak for
myself sort of assumed he's kind of
conservative and then you realize when
you view it through the lens of what's
happening in Ukraine John cornyn and
Mitch McConnell and Tom Tillis and
almost every Republican senator
is a screaming liberal actually and if
it weren't for foreign policy you
wouldn't know that you wouldn't know
that they are completely aligned with
Chuck Schumer and the Democrats in Joe
Biden so there really is a unit party on
these the most important questions
well there's obviously an ideological
disease that courses through Washington
when it comes to foreign policy and the
sacrifice of our interest to foreign
Nations and foreign profits but it's
even deeper than that and I know this
because I also worked on the hill for
almost a decade the intelligence
Community is able to manipulate the
intelligence process and their
relationship with lawmakers in order to
obtain the answers that they want from
Congress so when it comes to an issue
like the Patriot Act they can link what
they need to leak they can push the
narratives they need to push they can
manufacture the threats they need to
manufacture and they can work the
relationships that they have in order to
obtain the outcome that they want and
that has always been true on foreign
policy for many many many years then
Donald Trump comes up onto the scene of
Washington a man over with whom they
have no relationship a man who has no
affinity for them who doesn't care about
them who doesn't value what they value
and this for them is a panic moment it
is a panic moment and we are now living
in the seventh year of that panic
turning our entire democracy upside down
and I will tell you if a prosecutor in
Manhattan can take control of our entire
presidential election process Now by
what definition can we say that we even
have a democracy in this country right
no I mean we were mocked I thought
justly by the president of El Salvador
yesterday he said we're not going to
take any more lectures about democracy
from a country that interferes in its
own elections like this and and
unfortunately he's right he is Stephen
Miller great to see you tonight thank
you for that
thank you subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube channel to catch our nightly
opens stories that are changing the
world and changing your life from Tucker
Carlson tonight